well according to our akashic reader we
do go way back in time but we're not
going to get to that yet um that's the
that's that's the second part of this
the first part is the stuff that
everyone knows you for it's the stuff
that i knew you for
um
and that's food and that's fitness um
and i totally
i'm such a stickler for form and i'm
like your form has always been
incredible i'm like this girl knows what
she's doing
yes i love hearing that so how i i'm
curious
how you even how you got into
was it food first was it fitness first
what was the impetus to really launch
you into
wellness damn i've never used the word
impetus i'm going to add that to my
vocabulary now so thank you learning so
many things and so many words from you
so i
uh was definitely into fitness first i
uh grew up
hating myself hating my body hating just
like everything about myself it was so
sad and so the first thing that i was
introduced to was fitness
and i started working out in high school
in a gym and so i'd go run red rocks
amphitheater
just to get outside and then
in college i would do you know two hours
on the stair master when you're like you
know oh i know hanging on i would do
that on the elliptical or something like
that and i laugh at people now but
with love but i did it i can only laugh
at them because i've done it yeah and
you don't know what else to do yeah you
don't and
the weight room felt so intimidating it
was all good guys so i was too scared to
do that i didn't feel in shape so i
would just do elliptical stairmaster
bike
and then
in college i met a guy i started dating
this guy and he was doing crossfit
workouts and so he introduced me to
crossfit
i went on crossfit.com i couldn't do a
push-up i couldn't do a pull-up what
year was this then this would have been
2008
dang you got into crossfit og days oh
man they were still doing it at the
ranch back then yes they were and i saw
these crossfit females
that they would put they put a picture
every day with the workout back in the
day they put a picture up and it was
these incredibly strong females and so i
started i couldn't do any of those
movements by myself so i started going
to a gym where i couldn't find a little
corner and i would do push-ups on my
knees and then i would do the assisted
dip machine and the assisted pull-up and
start building up strength
building confidence in the gym and then
before i knew it i was at the rec center
at college and i was you know doing
overhead squats and i was doing double
unders and ring dips and it just kind of
grew from there
but what really stuck with me so much
with crossfit was i went to
crossfit used to have sectionals then
regionals and the games wow and so i
went to a sectionals in town i like uh
volunteered at this event
and all the women were so kind to each
other they were so there's so much
camaraderie yeah and kindness and
cheering each other on and i saw every
body type too there were really skinny
women there were really thick women
bigger like there was just every shape
and size and you thought like the woman
who looked the most in shape
in shape would do the best and then it
was a completely different person and i
just loved that about crossfit it didn't
it wasn't about how you looked it was
how you performed yeah and the weight
you got and the pr you got and the time
you got i just loved those those new
numbers instead of what was on the scale
totally and so crossfit just hooked me
in it got me i loved it i joined a
crossfit gym in college at the end of
college
i started competing and when i started
competing that's when i got into food
and crossfit was really big into the
zone diet
first
yes really
i mean i only know
paleo and crossfit to be like boyfriend
girlfriend but i had no idea it was the
zone so i think rob wolf was really into
zone back then
and
so they had like a whole diet page that
was all about zone diet and have you
ever heard of zone diet of course yeah
40 30 30. yes right like 40 40 protein
30 carbs 30 fat yes yeah and you're
getting you know your three blocks or
one block is like three almonds one or
one block is like one macadamia nut and
like still remember these things because
i packed little containers of like
almonds from the day here's my box block
of almonds here's my box block of
chicken yes and i would measure out
everything and that was the first
introduction to
healthy food yeah my boyfriend at the
time was jacked i'm like why don't i
look like you if i do the same workouts
as you he's like well your diet is [ __ ]
you
i have a terrible diet and i mean i was
eating the worst food you could eat
waffles for breakfast i would oh my god
i would eat literally animal crackers
like the coated frosted coated animal
yum with the sprinkles yes
with frosting danica with frosting with
frosting you're an overachiever
i already know that i know that about
you especially now but when i go hard
into something like eating bad i go hard
and so i got into the zone diet and i
started to lose weight and saw my body
change and i saw my performance increase
my numbers in the gym started going up
strength wise
and i just felt better i for once in my
life i didn't have a stomach ache i
didn't know what that was like i just
thought everybody had stomach aches at
all times right and gas and digestion it
was just part of life and once i did
zone
that all ended and
then crossfit started getting in paleo
yep so i was like
crossfit i see you i'm in it i started
getting into paleo again i felt so much
better cutting out grains cutting out
gluten cutting out dairy
my
body just felt so good yeah i just wake
up with so much energy for sure
and so
i competed in crossfit for years and
then while i was competing i was
creating recipes because i didn't know
how to cook at all so i just like wait a
minute you're creating recipes but you
didn't know how to cook those things
don't really go together that's true so
creating recipes is really hard for
people to think they can cook it's true
well i was like okay overachiever
i have to learn how to have banana bread
still got it and so then it's like oh
you can have almond flour you can have
coconut flour and that was back when
that stuff was really hard to get yes
like it's been it's only more recently
that you can find coconut flour almond
flour you know all the different flours
and the different fat even ghee i mean
like i don't even know if it was common
to find ghee and ghee you know because
ghee doesn't have the the milk in it so
stuff like that was even not even that
common so yeah i would order a lot of
stuff online there was a website called
tropical traditions or nuts.com so i
would order stuff online
but whole foods would usually have
almond flour but it was like
i couldn't imagine it was so expensive
especially where i was out in life i'm
like how do i afford this
but i ate a lot of nut butter i baked a
lot of things with nut butter it was
like almond butter was my survival back
then yeah um and so i started learning
how to cook i would look at i would look
at magazines and something that caught
my eye i'm like well how do i make that
paleo and so i would start seeing how
they paired ingredients together like
spices together or seasonings um how
they seared a steak i would kind of read
up on that and i watched the cooking
channel non-stop back then so did i yes
and you learn so much from watching
other people do it thanks emerald cassie
you started it off
yes
and like giada and even rachel ray
totally yeah her stuff was so simple you
could she's not even professionally
trained you know that yeah she doesn't
even she didn't go to culinary school
she just figured it out that just shows
like how much you can learn on the fly
and get really good at stuff and do it
constantly over and over you're going to
continue to get better at it with
anything in life
and
i was sending all of my friends recipes
like texting them recipes or emailing
them recipes that i had made up because
that i would bring like these no-bake
cookies cherry-made or protein cookies
they're like well how do you make these
and so i text them or email them and
then someone one day was like you should
start a blog and i had no idea what a
blog was
i had never even heard the word it was
so new back then yeah in 2011.
um
and yeah my friend literally was like
yeah i'll just help you set up this like
free website you just
like got the domain and help me put up
this little crappy website and i just
started paleomg